i've kind of converted the bedroom into
only bedroom activities you know um and
not a place where i work
you know
that's um do you take you know do you
take naps at all
i do i'm a big napper i love taking a 20
minute nap or doing an nsdr in the
afternoon the rule on naps and matt
walker and i agree on this is that
nap should be shorter than 90 minutes
and they should um you should only take
them if they if they don't disrupt your
nighttime sleep
i love naps i'm cons and i can sleep
anywhere anytime now because i do the
nsdr so if i just decide i'm gonna lie
down and pass out i can just do that it
just happens and i um
so i'm big on naps for a couple of
reasons um there are several very good
papers that were published in the last
few years in the journal cell report
showing that short
naps and nsdr i should say has some good
science to support it
accelerates neuroplasticity and learning
especially if you take that nap within
four to six hours after a very intense
learning bout there's something about
that
sleep state that allows the brain to
rewire and most of the rewiring and
neuroplasticity occurs during deep sleep
but also during these short sleep mounts
um that we call naps or nsdr so i'm a
huge fan
you mentioned long exhales
in the context of the yoga neutral
practice
is it fair to refer to that yoga nidra
practice is also
non-sleep deep rest or nsdr are those
separate phenomena
yeah so yoga nidra is one of several
what we call nsdr non-sleep deep rest
protocols admittedly i coined the term
nsdr because scientists like acronyms
almost as much as the military likes
acronyms and i did it deliberately
not to rob
the beautiful history and community that
is yoga nidra and the yogic communities
of anything but rather because many
people are averse to doing anything that
has a name like yoga nidra and yet it's
such a powerful tool it's a zero cost
tool that has enormous effects on not
just accessing sleep and calm but
enhancing rates of neuroplasticity
something that we could talk more about
also david spiegel
again our associate chair of psychiatry
at stanford a close collaborator and
friend of mine is a world expert in
clinical hypnosis
we are part of a just in in full
disclosure we both sit on the advisory
board of a company called reverie
r-e-v-e-r-i dot com reverie is a
zero-cost app
on android and apple that
has short hypnosis protocols anywhere
from
10 minutes to 15 minutes
hypnosis and yoga nidra both fall under
the umbrella of nsdr non-sleep depressed
and these are protocols that
people can use to deliberately access
states of deep rest for sake of
again falling asleep more easily
reducing stress but also for enhancing
rates of learning of neuroplasticity and
because these are zero cost tools i and
because they're grounded in excellent
peer-reviewed research i feel
comfortable mentioning them
and what you find is that
if people who are not familiar with
meditation or mindfulness or maybe
they're not from west la or the bay area
um if they hear yoga nidra they think
magic carpets and they think and they
hear hypnosis and they think that
somebody's going to control their brain
nsdr is my attempt to create a more
friendly language which is because all
of these things are really just the same
thing they really involve two things one
self-directing a state of calm that's
something that we never learn how to do
unless we have a need to do it we suffer
some trauma we have chronic stress
we start taking a mindfulness class we
self-inducing a state of calm through
respiration and vision is the hallmark
of yoganidra and hypnosis and frankly of
all meditative practices our thoughts
follow our vision and breathing and i
can explain why that is in a moment
in addition
these nsdr type practices
involve not just self-directing calm but
they also involve directing our focus to
something
we generally have a hard time falling
asleep because we think we have to turn
off our thoughts completely like a
switch but the transition to sleep
involves allowing our thoughts to become
fragmented
and then we become relaxed and then the
brain enters the state where space and
time are very fluid and not under our
conscious control and those are things
that we can teach ourselves so yoga
nidra scripts are found all over
youtube there's some great apps out
there the zero cost ones that i use are
any of the stuff by comedy k a m i n i
desai d e s a i i like her voice very
much some people like my sister loves
liam gillen's voice another zero cost
yoga nidra tool liam gillen double
l-g-i-l-l-e-n
you have to find a voice that you like
the revery app is david's voice
he has a very hypnotic voice
and there are scripts in there for
smoking cessation stress and anxiety
sleep etc these i really want to
emphasize in addition to being zero
costs are very powerful tools if done
regularly there are two papers that were
published in the last two years from
cell reports and cell press journal
excellent journal showing that a
20-minute non-sleep deep breath protocol
after a bout of intense focus or intense
attempt to learn anything skill learning
or cognitive learning
accelerates plasticity by about 50
so you are learning faster much faster
and retention of that information
lasts much longer and that's because
these are sleep-like states and we know
that neuroplasticity the brain's ability
to change in response to experience is
triggered by
high focus by deliberate periods of very
high focus but the actual rewiring of
neurons the formation of new synapses
and the reordering of the circuitry that
leads to that skill or that cognitive
ability
becoming reflexive
that happens in states of deep rest
and non-sleep deep breast nsdr whether
it's hypnosis or yoga needra or a
shallow nap of about 20-30 minutes
those things will all accelerate
learning one thing that's really um i
should mention if people are having an
afternoon crash
uh one thing they can do to support
themselves is to um delay their morning
caffeine for 90 to 120 minutes after
waking the longer you're awake the more
there's a build up of a of a molecule in
the brain and body called adenosine
and that's sort of a sleepiness molecule
if you will caffeine inhibits adenosine
function it does this through a it
basically parks in the receptor and
prevents adenosine from working so if
you wake up in the morning
and you're blitzing caffeine like i am
this morning um but i've been up for a
while
you're drinking caffeine straight out
the gate what happens is whatever
residual adenosine was in your system is
still floating around you've blocked
where it can bind to the adenosine
receptor so it's not making you sleepy
but then
sometime right around one or two pm when
that caffeine wears off all of a sudden
there's this glut of adenosine and you
feel tired when you wake up in the
morning if you delay caffeine
the cortisol peak actually is able to
clear out the remaining adenosine that
happens to be around but it requires uh
it gets a little technical but it
requires an interaction with the
receptor so if you keep caffeine out of
your system for the first 90 to 120
minutes of waking and then have your
caffeine you'll notice that you'll push
through the afternoon just fine without
any um afternoon drop it also allows you
to drink less caffeine overall because a
lot of people are just habitual coffee
drinkers
[Music]
you